Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux !
Aujourd'hui, j'ai l'immense plaisir
d'accueillir dans l'atelier un ami
enfin plutôt deux
amis, Philippe Geluck et son Chat.
- Bonjour Philippe.
-  Bonjour Jamy.
Ça va bien ?
Oui, je parle à sa place parce que lui,
si on le laisse face à lui-même,
ce n'est rien, c'est
juste une feuille de papier.
Est-ce que Le Chat est devenu
Epicurieux ?
Parce que la dernière fois qu'il s'est
exprimé, Épicurieux n'existait pas.
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
il est devenu Épicurieux ?
Alors je ne te demande pas
la réponse immédiate
parce que c'est Le Chat qui va s'exprimer
et qui va s'exprimer à travers un dessin.
On va attendre la fin de notre entretien.
C'est une question que je t'ai posée
en préparant cet échange
et on aura la réponse
à la fin de l'entretien.
Comment il va Le Chat
au bout de 40 ans ?
Il est égal à lui-même.
Toujours facétieux,
farceur, crétin ou philosophe.
Je l'ai inventé un peu par hasard
pour le journal Le Soir en mars 1983.
Et ce 24ᵉ album est dense parce qu'il fait
64 pages au lieu de 48 habituelles
et parce que 24 albums, c'est
un chiffre symbolique pour moi
puisque c'est le nombre d'albums
de Tintin produits par Hergé.
Vous formez un tandem :
il ne vieillit pas.
Non, moi en revanche, j'ai perdu
quelques cheveux,
mais dont j'ai fait des pinceaux
pour les couleurs.
Il ne vieillit pas,
non c'est ça qui est magique
avec un personnage de fiction.
À chaque fois que je te vois, j'ai
l'impression de parler à deux personnes
parce que parfois
tu peux dire quelque chose
mais je me dis : dans sa tête,
comment Le Chat est en train
d'analyser cette situation ?
Les choses sont très claires,
il y a lui et il y a moi.
Quand il dit une connerie,
c'est lui qui s'exprime,
quand il dit quelque chose d'intelligent,
c'est moi qui parle par sa bouche.
Ah c’est bien, c'est facile !
Je pense que Le Chat peut parfois balancer des horreurs
sur des sujets graves,
grinçants et son regard
qui est toujours bienveillant
pour les faibles, pour ceux qui
souffrent, pour les victimes,
il est toujours du côté de ceux-là
et je pense
que les lecteurs le comprennent bien.
Il n'est jamais cynique,
il n'est jamais odieux
ou s'il est odieux,
c'est pour faire rire
et on sait très bien
que c'est pour faire rire.
Mon but, mon envie, c'est
de surprendre par le thème abordé,
par la forme que j'adopte, par la couleur
ou le noir et blanc, et surtout
en me disant que quand on l'attend
sérieux, il est déconnant
et quand on l'attend idiot,
il dit une chose très sensée.
Alors en revanche, il y a des thèmes
qui reviennent régulièrement.
Je pense aux talibans.
Oui, je ne les aime pas.
Et ça se voit.
C'est à chaque fois ancré
dans le contexte, dans l'actualité.
Voilà, qui pour certains thèmes
malheureusement, comme les violences
faites aux plus faibles,
comme la faim dans le monde,
comme la pollution, comme l'intégrisme,
etc. sont des thèmes larges
et qui seront encore présents
quelques années je le crains.
Les cons en prennent
pour leur grade.
Beaucoup !
Mais ça je voudrais les remercier,
mais je ne sais pas s'ils nous écoutent.
Je pense qu'il n'y a pas de cons
qui soient vraiment Épicurieux.
- Enfin en général, on ne le sait pas.
- Soi-même.
Mais alors si, je connais des cons
qui se sont mis à regarder
et à suivre Epicurieux et tout à coup
ils sont devenus des gens formidables.
Donc la connerie est une maladie
qui n'est pas là pour toujours,
on peut la soigner.
Merci Docteur.
Comment naissent tous ces dessins,
toutes ces petites histoires ?
Je n'en sais rien.
Ce sont des idées qui “pi” !
Il y a une idée qui vient
alors je l'écris sur un papier
ou je la dessine tout de suite.
Quand je fais un dessin
et que mes collaborateurs
me voient rire en dessinant,
ils se disent "ça, ça va être un bon dessin !"
Tu n’utilises pas l'actualité,
mais l'air du temps
moi il y en a une qui m'a beaucoup
fait sourire,
c'est celle des hommes-grenouilles,
des plongeurs.
C'est au moment du confinement,
des masques, etc. et j'ai dessiné
deux hommes-grenouilles en appelant ça
“L'humour chez les hommes-grenouilles”.
Et il y en a un
qui montre un petit carton à l'autre
en disant :
"Le port du masque est obligatoire".
Je pense que dans les années à venir,
si les confinements et les virus
genre Covid ne nous emmerdent plus,
les hommes-grenouilles
vont continuer à porter le masque.
On a parlé de facétie,
c'est très caustique aussi.
Il y a ce dessin qui parle
de diabète et de caramel.
“Quand on incinère un diabétique,
ça sent le caramel.”
Bon, faut oser quand même !
- On peut rire de tout ?
- Oui.
Oui, je pense qu'on peut rire
de tout
et j'ai quelques dessins aussi
sur le handicap.
J'ai fait récemment un dessin
et j'ai oublié de le mettre dans l'album.
Et pourtant je l'aime bien
donc il sera dans le suivant, réservez
déjà le 25ᵉ album chez votre libraire.
Et c'est Le Chat qui parle à un enfant
qui est dans un fauteuil roulant
et il lui dit : “Qu'est-ce que tu voudras
faire plus tard ?”
et le gamin lui répond : "Du stand-up !”.
Et oui.
Et tu sais que des personnes en fauteuil,
des personnes handicapées
viennent me voir
lors de séances de dédicaces
pour me dire : “Merci
de nous inclure dans vos dessins.
On se sent mieux,
on se sent plus faire partie de la société
alors qu'il y a tellement de signes
qui nous en excluent.”
Parce que c'est drôle, Le Chat est drôle,
il ne se moque pas.
Alors dans la même veine,
il y a celle aussi sur
Kennedy, à part avoir été assassiné,
qu'est ce qu'il a fait dans sa vie ?
Oui, on ne sait plus.
Mais il est très connu.
Il est très connu
pour avoir été assassiné.
Mais en même temps,
ça en dit beaucoup de notre société
parce que tout le monde connaît Kennedy
mais demandez à n'importe qui
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ?
Est-ce que tu as un chat ?
Mais un vrai là, en chair et en os
et avec des poils ?
Mais je te trouve très curieux, toi.
C'est ma vie privée, ça.
Non, je n'ai pas de chat.
Autre chose alors là que j'adore,
c'est ton jeu avec les mots,
mais ce ne sont pas forcément
des jeux de mots, c'est plus subtil.
Merci.
Je vais envoyer un petit mot à Victor Hugo
pour lui dire : “Tu vois bien
que le jeu de mots n'est pas forcément
la fiente de l'esprit qui vole.”
C'est bien.
Absolument.
En revanche, je note que Le Chat
aime faire des démonstrations,
qu'il aime aussi la biologie avec les différents sens, qu'il aime les mots.
Il aime aussi l'histoire,
il aime les chiffres.
De temps en temps,
il parle d'Einstein.
Tout ça, c'est très Épicurieux.
Le Chat est-il Épicurieux ?
La réponse est oui !
C'est pas à cette question-là qu'il répond.
Il t’en pose une autre.
Comment fait-on pour transformer un vilain défaut en une immense qualité ?
J'ai toujours entendu dire quand j'étais
môme : “La curiosité est un vilain défaut.”
Et là, vous nous apportez la preuve inverse :
qu'être curieux est une immense qualité.
D'ailleurs,
des scientifiques l'ont prouvé
c'est que c'est la curiosité
qui a permis à l'Homme
d'évoluer vers ce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui.
La curiosité, c'est plutôt un joli défaut.
Merci beaucoup Philippe d'avoir fait
le chemin jusqu'ici, jusque dans l'atelier.
Je souhaite bien évidemment
un immense succès
à ce 24ᵉ album.
Un bon anniversaire au Chat.
Et encore une fois,
je le dis, ce qui est génial avec Le Chat,
c'est qu'on peut relire deux fois,
trois fois, dix fois les histoires,
on rit toujours !